juin 2014
en poste depuis un mois et demi carlos
leitao invite les médias ici mais au
ministère des finances à la veille du
dépôt de son tout premier budget et
comme le veut la tradition il s'est
acheté une nouvelle paire de chaussures
mais pas n'importe lesquels ce sont des
chaussures différentes les routes
ce sont des chaussures de marche ça
reflète la relance de l'économie
si rien n'est fait pour rétablir la
situation le ministre après en un
déficit de 6 milliards de dollars en
2014 et 7 milliards en 2015
une déléguée par le parti québécois à
cause de sa mauvaise gestion répète le
gouvernement il avait trouvé son
principal argument pour justifier ce que
plusieurs appellerons l'austérité n'est
pas d'austérité
c'est une crise d'une vue de l'esprit on
est dans une période de rigueur
budgétaire
le conseil du trésor impose une cure
minceur pour atteindre l'équilibré
budgétaire sa stratégie ralentir la
croissance des dépenses de l'état et
appliquer ce qu'il appelle un cran
d'arrêt c'est à dire que toute nouvelle
dépense doit être compensée par des
compressions la pertinence de l'ensemble
des services gouvernementaux est aussi
revu
les négociations pour renouveler les
conventions collectives du secteur
public sont houleuses mais le
gouvernement couillard réussir à
s'entendre avec la majorité des employés
de l'état avant la fin de son mandat
le déficit d'appréhender menace aussi le
système québécois des garderies selon
philippe couillard il mersey au tarif
unique même s'il avait promis de
seulement les indexer en campagne
électorale
désormais le coût varie en fonction du
revenu des parents lynch non je n'ai pas
super en pleine contradiction avec ce
que promis durant la campagne électorale
une autre promesse électorale semble
tout à coup un certaine les libéraux
s'est engagé à favoriser la création de
250 mille nouveaux emplois sur cinq ans
mais le début du mandat est marquée par
la fermeture de plusieurs usines jeu se
poursuivre au niveau des travailleurs de
cascades à east angus
electrolux à l'assomption et au dot à la
chine se bute à des portes closes eia
publiera oncle fut un cauchemar quand
l'usiné de pâte irrésolu ferme à
shawinigan
le ministre jacques daoud met en place
qui la paient leur groupe tactique
d'intervention économique spécifiquement
pour la mauricie
l'une des régions les plus touchées par
les pertes d'emplois
le gouvernement interviendra aussi dans
le secteur de l'aéronautique
actuellement ce qu'on fait je t'enlève
chemin le gouvernement investit un
milliard de dollars américains dans
bombardier pour l'aider à compléter le
développement de la cseries et deux ans
plus tard coup de tonnerre jours
j'ai un airbus prend les commandes du
programme cette transaction est la seule
issue qui nous permet d'avoir un avenir
viable pour la syrie c'est est ce que le
premier ministre va poser des gestes une
voiture à plat ventre et le gouvernement
affronte un feu nourri de critiques
quand rona et saint-hubert deux fleurons
québécois pensent aux mains des
américains et des ontariens ronald à ses
relents et napoléon merlan et napoléon
sont maintenant amérique est rattrapé
par des révélations concernant la vente
controversée les actions de rona le
ministre jacques da ou démissionne
dans un mémoire publié après sa mort il
affirme que le cabinet du premier
ministre l'a forcé à dire publiquement
qu'il était d'accord avec la vente alors
qu'ils ne l'étaient pas
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on peut dire que le québec
va mieux et on a tenu parole l'année
financière 2015 2016 marque une nouvelle
ère québec nage dans les surplus
budgétaires
après avoir fermé le robinet des
dépenses pendant deux ans le
gouvernement ouvre les vannes et
l'habilitation de tout le tronçon
ferroviaire
c'est 100 millions de demain dit le
printemps il y aura des travaux sans une
nouvelle classe de maternelle 4 un
temple est en milieu défavorisé 600
millions $ dont le déploiement de cette
politique culturelle
[Musique]
au printemps 2008 le taux de chômage
s'établissait à 5,3 pour cent en deçà de
la moyenne nationale et les libéraux le
souligner à grands traits il s'agit du
taux le plus bas depuis des décennies
nous avons les auteurs du plus grand
redressement financier économique de
l'histoire récente du québec la province
atteint le plein emploi la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre inquiète de plus en plus
et l'autre menace économique à l'horizon
si lui ne brille guère l'ombre comme une
exclusion de donald d'imposer une taxe
sur les importations de bois d'oeuvre
des tarifs sont l'acier l'aluminium
canadien fort ce gouvernement fournir de
l'aide financière les négociations
difficiles dans le cadre de l'alena
laisse présager une guerre commerciale
peut être même une récession nous allons
avoir un programme pour soutenir les
quelques cent soixante dix huit
entreprises québécoises qui sont touchés
par la décision du gouvernement
américain durant ses deux premières
années le gouvernement couillard a placé
le pied sur le frein des défenses pour
ensuite appuyé sur l'accélérateur
[Musique]